Selena Gomez is one supportive  girlfriend let me show you how an  tomatoes Selena attended her boyfriend  the weekends concert in Brazil on Sunday  the good for you singer was spotted  smiling from ear to ear while proudly  watching her beau perform from backstage  it's extremely touching it's amazing at  one point  Selena even appeared on the jumbotron  bobbing her head to the star boy singers  hit song The Weeknd posted a video of  himself coming to the stage to a crowd  of cheering fans it seems like Selena  may have filmed the cute clip of her  beau as she posted a pic of her man from  the same angle on her Instagram story  [Music]  you  [Music]